Some of the things we're gonna need when we're gonna clean the cut are some sterile water...
...and some gauze bandages.
The first step when we're going to clean a cut is to make sure that the bleeding has stopped.
Once the bleeding has stopped, what we're gonna do is we're gonna take some sterile water.
And with this sterile water, we're gonna take it and we're gonna flush the wound out.
We can either do that by pouring the water over the cut...
...or we can take a gauze bandage and soak the gauze bandage with water.
Once we do that, we'll clean the wound out good,...
...make sure that there's no debris or dirt or anything like that inside the cut.
After we finish getting that out, making sure that there's no dirt left in the cut...
...we'll take a new clean gauze dressing, and we'll make sure that the cut is dry.
Before we bandage the cut, we don't want to have any water left on there...
...because water can breed germs.
So, we wanna make sure that the dirt is all cleaned out the cut...
...and that everything is dry before we start bandaging.
My name is Nathan McConnell and this has been "How to Clean a Cut".